let's think about how a tax on a product
might affect it if it is if the demand
for it is very very very elastic so what
I've done here we're gonna think about
flags the market for a certain type of
flag that's made in China and to think
about this flag think about it this way
if the price the price right now the
equilibrium price between where the
supply and the demand intersect the
supply curve in the demand curve
intersect is right at about $70 per flag
so this is a pretty nice flag it's right
at $70 per flag and the quantity
demanded in thousands per year looks
like it's about 25 thousand flags are
demanded per year now if the price were
to go slightly above that equilibrium
price what's going to happen well the
price goes slightly above that
equilibrium price people can say well I
can go by the American flags made in
Taiwan or even the ones made in America
are made in Mexico are made someplace
else at least for when it's out on my
you know people will be able to tell the
difference from a distance so I'm going
to buy one of the substitutes especially
for the ones from Taiwan or Mexico or
wherever else are identical to the ones
made in China so if the price were
slightly even slightly higher the
quantity demanded would be much much
much lower and if the price were even a
little bit lower then people say well
I'm not gonna buy the Mexican flags or
the Taiwanese American flags I'm going
to buy the ones that were made in China
and then the quantity demanded would be
much larger and so what we you have here
is a very large very very high
elasticity of demand so this right over
here this is almost perfectly elastic if
it was perfectly elastic it would be
completely horizontal so this is almost
almost perfectly perfectly elastic
elastic demand a very small change in
price leads to a huge change in quantity
and particular very small percent change
in price leads to a huge percent change
in quantity so let's say that that some
government official decides you know
what I they don't like the idea of
American
being made in China so they decide to
tax American flags made in China so what
they do is that they place a tax they
place the taxes once again onto a fixed
dollar tax it could be a percentage and
if a percentage then it'll change the
supply plus tax curve it'll be it'll the
the shift will will be a percentage
change instead of a fixed change but the
fixed change is a little bit easier to
draw so I'll do that so let's say that
there is a tax let me do that in a
different color let's say that there is
a tax placed of $10 $10 per flag $10
actually let's do it even let's do even
a smaller amount let's say there's a tax
placed of of $1.00 per flag $1.00 per
flag I'll make it a little bit larger
let's say it's $5 per flag $5 per flag
so now what is the supply plus tax curve
so the supplier just to make the Flags
in China and ship them to the United
States and get them to a store here too
even to get that first flag done even if
it's said in the most efficient way
possible you need at least looks like
around 50 to 53 dollars now they're
going now they're still going to need
that plus there's going to be a $5 tax
on it so the supply plus tax is going to
be that plus $5 so it's gonna be right
around there over here yeah add $5 so at
any given point we're gonna add $5 to
essentially what the consumer would have
to see so you would have a curve that
looks at something like this you would
have a curve that looks something like
this so this is that dotted line right
over there is our supply is our supply
plus tax this right over here was just
our supply was just our supply so you're
essentially so let's think about what
happens here your equilibrium price was
at 70 before now our equilibrium price
is still our equilibrium price is still
pretty much at 70 but our equilibrium
quantity has gone down dramatically our
equilibrium quantity has gone down too
our equilibrium quantity has gone down
too I don't know it looks like about
18,000 18,000 Flags per year so who bore
who board the bulk of this right over
here so let's think about the tax
revenue so the tax revenue in this
situation
is going to be 18,000 times a $5 so this
is the $5 right over here that is $5 and
then times 18,000 times
18,000 so this right over here is the
tax revenue that right over there is a
tax revenue actual let me draw it a
little bit more carefully so the tax
revenue is so it's going to be between
this line right over here and five
dollars so just like that so that's all
the tax revenue and notice it all came
out of the producer surplus the original
producer surplus the original producer
surplus was especially if we assume
perfect elasticity the original producer
surplus was this green rectangle plus
this and plus this now this is going to
be this little area right over here is
going to be deadweight loss deadweight
loss and all of that came from the
producers surplus and then all the tax
revenue also if you especially if you
assume this top line was horizontal also
came out of the producer surplus so in
this situation where you had almost or
we could say if you do have perfect
elasticity if you have perfect
elasticity of demand for the product the
person who's going to bear the brunt of
the tax so is going to be the producer
the producer surplus is going to be
eaten into from the tax bears bears the
actually that's I'm done I'm not talking
about the animal bears so the producer
well the producer gets the burden the
producer the producer gets the burden in
that situation and this is an
interesting thing to think about because
when you have almost perfectly elastic
demand so almost where if you said
perfectly elastic demand a flat a flat
demand curve right over here there's
there's actually no consumer surplus
because the marginal benefit even the
incremental marginal or I'm being
redundant with words incremental and
marginal but the marginal benefit at any
point for the consumer for that for that
next unit is equal to the price they're
paying when you have there's no there's
especially if the be especially if the
demand curve is perfectly elastic and
it's perfectly horizontal there is no
area between the demand curve
and the price paid so there's actually
there isn't any even any consumer
surplus to take any to take any of the
to take to eat into it all gets eaten
out of the out of the producer surplus